في هذا المكان المتواضع من خيام ومساكن
طينيه يسكن المعلم ومربي الاجيال علي
الوليد بمحافظه مارب بعد نجاته من قبضه
الحوثيين في مديريه الحيمه غربيه العاصمه
صنعاء حاله غيره من المعلمين اليمنيين
الذين استهدفتهم الميليشيات الحوثيه في
اطار استهدافها للعمليه التعليميه بشكل
عام قتلوا معظم المعلمين
وادخلهم الى الحبس حبسهم
وشردوهم وقطعوا راتبرهم هذا الاضرار التي
لحقت المعلم من قبل الحوثيين ثم ال-
المنهج نفسه غيره بدل ما كان منهج الوطني
غيره بمن منهج وافكار طائفيه يحتفل العالم
بيوم التعليم وقد تحولت مئات المدارس في
اليمن منذ سيطره الحوثيين على العاصمه
صنعاء قناه العسكريه وصارت مخرجات التعليم
الملغمه بافكار العنف والطائفيه والعنصريه
تساقط الى الموت في جبهات القتال
خالد بنفسها ياخذونهم من المدارس الى همم
عملوا لهم عمليه غسيل الدماغ في المراكز
حقهم ثم ياخذونهم الى الجبهات ويعملوا لهم
شهائد في الجبهات بل شهائد جامعي مش اللي
همم التعليم الثانوي الاعدادي شهائد جامعي
وهم في الجبهات فدمر والعمليه التعليميه
واصبح اليمن عاد عشرات السنين الى الوراء
بمناهج محرفه وبلا مرتبات يجبر المعلمون
تحت سطوه الحوثيين اداء عمليه تعليميه
والى مناطق سيطره الشرعيه فرك كثير منهم
لتحصين ابنائهم والتدريس هناك للحصول على
مرتبه يعول اسرهم
اضطرينا نمزح من همم من بلادنا همم حيث
انه لا يوجد مرتب وكذلك حفاظ على ابنائنا
من همم
التعليم حفظ على ابناء المواصلات التعليم
الكبار والصغار حتى
يكملوا عليهم المطلوب تفاخر الدول اريد
التعليمي ومخرجاته وتتراجع العمليه
التعليميه في اليمن عقودا الى الخلف ضمن
سياسه التجهيل التي تمارسها الميليشيات
الحوثيه